so i have an interesting setup over here
i have a magnetic field that is constant
and it's going straight out of as you
say the surface of this loop the
magnetic the the magnitude of the
magnetic field at any point of the
surface is going to be b
and what we what's interesting here is
this loop that we have this right part
of the loop is movable you can imagine
it's a cylinder here that can roll to
the right and the magnitude of its
velocity we're going to say is lowercase
v and this this cylinder let's say it
has length l
so given that you can see that we're
going to have a change in magnetic flux
why we're going to have a change in
magnetic flux or a change of magnetic
flux through the surface well if this
thing is moving to the right
if this thing is moving to the right
when its speed is v and it could be any
units meters per second or whatever it
is you're going to even though the
magnetic field itself is constant you're
actually going to be changing the area
the area that is i guess you can
contained by this loop and so that is
going to give us a change in flux and if
you have a change in flux that is going
to induce an electromagnetic
that's going to induce an electromotive
force or it's going to induce a voltage
in this loop which will cause a current
to flow so let's think about what that
electromotive force that's going to be
induced is going to be and i'm just
going to rewrite faraday's law right
over here faraday's law negative n
times our change in
our change in flux
and we're talking about the the well our
change in flux over change in let me
write that a little bit neater
our change in
flux over change in
time now the n is the number of loops
we're talking about so in this case n is
just going to be 1. and the negative
i've already complained a little bit
about it in previous videos this is
really just reminding us the math when
you when you're not using kind of proper
vector mathematics this just reminds us
that this emf is going to cause a
current to go through this loop and the
and the magnetic field that is induced
by that current will go against the
direction of our change in flux so
that's that's just something something
to remind us there so what we really
care about what we really care about is
our change in flux
over change in time so what is that
going to be let me just write it here
our change in flux
over change in time
well our change in flux in this case is
going to be our change in our the
magnitude of our magnetic field that is
going perpendicular to the surface
times the area
of our surface over
our change in time
and what is this going to be equal to
well b is constant it's not going to
change over the time that we care about
so the change in b times a it's really
just going to be b
times our change in area b times our
change in area over how much
over how much time goes by so what is
our change in area going to be so let's
say that we let delta t
so let's say delta t goes go happens
what is going to be our change in area
well let's let delta t go on so if delta
t goes on this this cylinder or if we
wait for you know t units of time
so or of t units of time go by
so let me do this in another color
so
let me see i have not used let's see so
i'm going to use
this color right over here
so
how far will we go after delta t
well we know the magnitude of our
velocity if you multiply the magnitude
of your velocity times your change in
time
that will give you the mag that will
give you your distance
and so your change in area is going to
be the amount of distances traveled
times the length of the rod
times the length of the rod which is
just that
so our change in area which is that area
right over there
our change in area our change in area
over that time is going to be the
distance this rod goes notice this rod
is going in a direction that is
perpendicular to the direction of the
magnetic field that's an important thing
to realize and so we have we have our
change in area is going to be this
change this dimension which is
how far the rod travels
times the length of the rod that's how
much area we gain that's how much it
increases our area increases so times
times
the length of the rod that's our change
in area so then we can substitute that
back over here so this is going to be
equal to
and this is going to be equal to we get
our b we have our change in time
and our change in area we just said is
going to be
it's going to be let me just write it
this way i could write it as the length
of our rod
times the magnitude of our velocity or
our speed times
our change in time
we'll change in time divided by change
in time those cancel out so our change
in our change in or our change in flux
over that time or rate or our average
our average rate of change in flux we
see simplifies to
the length of our rod
times the magnitude of our velocity or
our speed times the magnitude of the
magnetic field that is going
perpendicular to the surface
and this is something that you will see
many times in your in your physics class
this whole notion of hey if your rod
going in a perpendicular direction to a
magnetic field it induces an
electromotive force of lvb well this is
where it's coming from it's coming
directly from faraday's law and you can
say okay if it's if it's if that's
happening what direction is that is the
current going to actually flow in
well if the the magnetic field isn't
changing but since the area is
increasing the flux is increasing in the
in the upward direction so you could say
the flux is increasing in that direction
so the current that gets induced and the
the magnitude of the current is going to
be based on how much resistance we have
but the current is going to induce a
magnetic field that goes against our
change against our change in flux
so let's see if the current went
if the current
went
that way
if the current goes that way what will
happen so i'm going to take my right
hand out so if i take my right hand out
put my thumb in that direction
and if i were to loop my fingers around
if i were to loop my fingers around
this would if the if we went that way
this would describe this would induce a
magnetic field that goes like this
that goes like this so that actually
would enhance the flux going through the
or the change in flux we go in the same
direction of the change in flux and
we've already talked about this would
violate the the law of conservation of
energy so the current's going to go in
the other direction
the current is going to go in the other
direction it's going to go
in this case it's going to go clockwise
because the current is going to induce a
magnetic field once again i can take my
right hand out and try to draw
my right hand and we could see now the
direction my fingers go in are that way
and notice we're looking at the inside
of the surface so the inside of the
surface the surface area was increasing
so it's increasing the flux in you could
say i guess you could say the upward
direction we're getting more of those
more of the magnetic field in the upper
direction being contained in the area so
the magnetic field induced by the
current that is induced which is caught
or that current is caused by the
electromotive force and depend the
magnitude of the current is going to be
dependent on our resistance that's going
to go in the other direction it's going
to go down that way so uh
or it's going to induce a magnetic field
that is going to go downwards so the
current needs to be going clockwise